[Música]
para la mayoría de los humanos las
flatulencias son un alivio bienvenido un
incidente vergonzoso o una oportunidad
para una broma con gas pero para muchas
otras criaturas las flatulencias no son
motivo de
risa en lo profundo del reino animal las
flatulencias pueden servir para
intimidar como actos de autodefensa e
incluso armas de asesinato maloliente
las partes más olorosas del reino animal
no son letales pero pueden arruinar su
viaje a la playa Las foscas y los leones
marinos son conocidos por tener
flatulencias muy fétidas por su dieta
los pescados y mariscos tienen mucho
azufre en la digestión las bacterias
intestinales de los mamíferos
descomponen el azufre y los aminoácidos
con azufre para producir disulfuro de
hidrógeno un gas Con olor parecido a
huevos
podridos las focas y los leones marinos
no pueden evitar su flatulencia apestosa
pero algunos animales las despliegan
estratégicamente tanto la serpiente de
ocico de cerdo Oriental como la
serpiente coral de Sonora usan una
táctica llamada chasquidos de cloaca
esto implica succionar aire en su cloaca
un agujero utilizado para orinar defecar
y reproducirse y luego dispararlo Con un
fuerte
estallido Estos estallidos no son más
peligrosos que hel hedor de un león
marino pero son eficaces para ahuyentar
a los posibles
depredadores Mientras tanto la
flatulencia de larbas de verotti es
silenciosa y mortal contiene una clase
de sustancia química conocida como
homona que ha evolucionado
específicamente para paralizar a las
Termitas de hecho Esta homona es tan
poderosa que una sola flatulencia puede
inmovilizar a múltiples Termitas durante
hasta 3 horas o incluso matarlas
directamente De cualquier manera estas
flatulencias tóxicas le dan tiempo a las
larvas de Vero tidda para devorar presas
de hasta tres veces su tamaño
para otros animales retener las
flatulencias puede ser
mortal el pez cachorrito de Bolsón es un
pez de Agua Dulce que vive al norte de
México que se alimenta de algas y otros
pequeños organismos en el sedimento pero
durante los días más calurosos del
verano esta alga produce mucho gas si un
pes cachorrito no tira este gas se
vuelve flotante y presa fácil para las
aves y no solo deben preocuparse por los
depredadores la acumulación excesiva de
gas puede reventar sus sistemas
digestivos investigadores han encontrado
cientos de peces cachorrito muertos que
no expulsaron sus flatulencias por
suerte para la humanidad las
flatulencias de animales no afectan al
ser humano solo nos hacen perder el
hambre pero en ciertas circunstancias
algo de flatulencia animal Puede crear
condiciones muy
peligrosas en el otoño de 2015 una
alarma de humo activada forzó a un avión
a hacer un aterrizaje de emergencia tras
una nueva inspección los oficiales
descubrieron que no había fuego solo
eructos y flatulencias de más de 2000
cabras transportadas en la bodega el
cambio en la presión del aire había
provocado que emitieran gases en masa
por suerte esta historia de cabras
flatulentas tuvo costos muy
bajos Pero la flatulencia más peligrosa
del mundo puede provenir de un mamífero
Igualmente Modesto la humilde
vaca hay casi 1 millones de vacas en el
mundo la mayoría de ellas criadas para
la leche y la carne las vacas son
rumiantes lo que significa que sus
estómagos tienen cuatro cámaras que les
permiten masticar digerir y regurgitar
la comida varias veces este proceso les
ayuda a extraer nutrientes adicionales
de sus alimentos pero también produce
mucho
gas esto es muy preocupante porque uno
de los gases que emiten las vacas es el
metano un importante gas de efecto
invernadero que contribuye en gran
medida al calentamiento global 1 kg de
metano atrapa decenas de veces más calor
en la atmósfera que 1 kg de dióxido de
carbono y dado que cada vaca libera
hasta 100 kg de metano cada año estos
animales se han convertido en uno de los
mayores contribuyentes al cambio
climático mientras que otros animales
pueden tener flatulencias más ruidosas
sucias o tóxicas La flatulencia de vaca
puede ser el gas más peligroso que jamás
se haya
[Música]
emitido Cómo corregimos nuestros
sistemas alimentarios visite
ed.ted.com
barclin echool para conocer los pasos
concretos que puede realizar ahora mismo
para ayudar a encausar al mundo hacia la
dirección correcta